alors malika comme vous êtes une
spécialiste des secrets regarder ce
grand tableau qui apparaît il y a le
secret de tous les chroniqueurs car
chacun en a un et vous allez devoir
attribuer le secret à un chroniqueur
j'étais huissier de justice
j'ai proposé une star du cinéma de
coucher avec moi j'ai une cicatrice sur
la fesse gauche encore benjamin ça
suffit on va on va pas le regarder à
chaque fois j'ai fait partie d'un groupe
de rap je fais la collection de
pantoufles j'étais enfant de choeur
je suis allergique aux cochons d'inde
j'étais un des plus grands fans des to
be fluent in situ si saint christophe
carrière christophe carrière ce que vous
avez été me situer alors pas du tout
j'ai eu affaire à eux mais pas du tout
bon sens je vous donne elle vous donne
un indice il est souvent bronzer
[Applaudissements]
big lol ah oui vous avez exercé à
l'absolution
c'est à libourne près de bordeaux et
c'était incroyable truc c'était cela dit
on a besoin d utile du style vocal et il
était un très beau métier où j'ai
beaucoup appris mais c'est vrai que j'ai
préféré le quitter très vite sa première
saisie c'était un point soleil
[Applaudissements]
je vais dire va te coucher avec moi qui
aurait pu dire ça que l'état alors
attention de rivière noter que dans la
question il ya g il a fait que proposez
vous allez j'ai pas fait il ou elle est
ce qu'on peut avoir fait de trucs staff
christophe est joué mais alors
totalement involontairement qui était
l'acheteur
alors c'est un homme justement oui ou
par un aveu en fait c'était mike myers
qui joue dans austin powers et il se
trouve que quand j'ai démarré ce métier
moi j'ai pas mon bac j'ai rien je pas
fait d'études et je ne savais pas parler
anglais mais judicieux évidemment j'ai
dit à tout le monde quand je parle
anglais y avait pas de problème donc
jean tu as vu max mayer vient comment
avec des agents se demande toujours s'il
n'arrêtait pas de me faire des vannes et
jules monde d'où lui vient cette envie
de me faire rire ah ouais et alors me
faire rire doigt un mec milan et non pas
huit mille love d'accord et la panique
est l'attaché de presse s'est déroulée
pour à l'interview vous me faites penser
région de ne plus faire ce jeu troisième
j'ai une cicatrice sur la fesse gauche
en fait c'est sous la fesse c'est
vraiment une grosse cicatrice au vôtre
c'est la loterie en fait quand j'étais
petit quand je suis né ils ont failli me
laisser tomber et la sage-femme à
rattraper comme ça avec ses deux doigts
c'était mon jour c'était super g à
coucher par wolverine ce que ça s'est
fait comme on l'a fait pour elle m'a
planté saison dans la famille unie comme
un bout de fesse ou s'explique
et vous savez c'est une histoire vraie
que moi quand mon jeu plus si c'est mon
fils ou ma fille a accouché aude et
arriver et on nous a dit on va pas
pouvoir accoucher tout de suite pourquoi
parce que l'enfant de monsieur castaldi
qui toujours pas sortie va falloir
qu'ils se sentent bien et elle est
attendue devant la porte qui veuille
bien rendu compte assez peu de petites
anecdotes de merde alors j'ai fait la
collection de pantouflard des cils
verdez et vougy perdant geraldine james
hill ravinois six mois alors oui mais
des peines avait combien chez vous
quinzaine mais des ponts fasse une belle
collection et pantoufles d'hommes
c'est même pas des collections ses
propres rangs tout comme ça je vois
c'est pourquoi je ris jaune c'est
exactement comment ça c'est façon la
presse après midi pour voilà enfin ce
credo j'ai rien là et se trouve un truc
parce que je suis embêté life demande
aux attaques à dire je collectionne les
pentes où elle fonda mes pantoufles en
velours à l'intérieur elles sont ma
classe et l on soit des glands soit des
broderies dacia des grands esprits de
ces matelas séquelles aiglons girolles
je sais que c'est du lourd
les cochons dance et vous maxime cet
allergique non je suis allergique à rien
du tout a alors quitté l'egypte en
touche mais moi les tests ont formelle
ça leur urine qui sèche et qui émet des
particules dans l'air qui me rendent
complexe car s'il nous fait uriner
dessus par des cochons et surtout c'est
ça que ça sèche alors une vraie europe
et alors là c'est terrible mais c'est
arrive souvent l'école chantal et ben
j'en avais on a fait des tests formel
j'ai été voir de nombreux professeurs
mais je suis là c'est du foutage de
gueule